hello freak [ __ ] why do these
patterns repeat themselves what is it
about human beings well we like things
simple we like things simple so-so and
then you often like a simple explanation
is a good explanation unless it's too
simple but distinguishing between simple
and too simple is no easy matter we like
we like to know who's our friend and
who's our enemy and we like the feeling
of unearned moral superiority and
unearned moral scatter yeah that's
that's the boy your niche and especially
when there's no such thing as earning
anyways so and then I mean there's
deeper and darker things that are
underneath that it's like the human
proclivity to pull down those who have
more than you it's like these kids on
the campuses who are claiming identity
with the oppressed you know what some
are like Yale it's like how in the world
you can speak of oppression if you
happen to be at Yale is beyond me I mean
first of all your North American which
puts you in the top one percent and then
of North Americans you're in the top 1%
to in the top 1% of 1% but yet you you
want that you want to have all the power
that goes along with that and you want
to have the moral superiority that comes
from being a representative of the
oppressed so that's exactly what you
want you want all the power and you want
all the victimization at the same time
well years Yale is a great example
because Yale was one of the what
happened with the Halloween costume
debacle at Yale was one of the first
videos that was released that made
people horrified where they couldn't
believe how students were communicating
with professors yeah well though a
student who screamed up a storm about
about that the male professor who was
the husband of the woman who wrote that
Pro Halloween costume letter it turned
out she was on the bloody hiring
committee that hired him one of the
things she screamed was who hired you
was like well it turned out it was you
because you were on the committee just a
few years before I know when they took
it like yeah that was absolutely all the
people that don't know what what the
hell were talking about well explain
this debacle because it really was about
questionable Halloween costumes well it
was about
questioning Halloween costumes Halloween
costumes are part of the whole point of
Halloween is to have questionable
costumes right you play with death for
example and decay and and horror and and
it's it's a time when the norms with
regards to the expression of things that
are outside of our normal behavior are
suspended so that everybody can can have
a little celebration as it turns out
well you know campuses have got all
upset about things like cultural
appropriation at Queen's University in
Canada just the other week they were
going after students who were dressing
up as Vietcong for example or Mexicans
it's like I just don't see what the
hell's racist about dressing up like a
Mexican Mexicans have a traditional
traditional clothing there's nothing
wrong with Mexicans so why is it wrong
address up like right and if you want to
be punch oviya for halloween what's
wrong with that
what would you you can you can regard
that as an Amar's just as much as a
denigration that's like why is that such
a problem right but anyways it doesn't
matter because nothing's too trivial to
be a problem to a social justice warrior
and because they don't like to deal with
real problems and yale went after
halloween cost so this woman wrote a
letter saying maybe we should just relax
about this stuff and you know not don't
put restrictions on what people wear for
Halloween but let people decide what is
and isn't offensive yes and well and
then many Halloween costumes are
offensive that's the point
but her letter wasn't really reason I
was perfectly reasonable it was like an
it was like an adult wrote it yes yeah
and and you know all hell broke loose
fall help and she ended up she ended up
quitting and I think he did you know I
don't think I don't think he left I
don't think he left but she did seeing
him bow down to this woman screaming at
him swearing in his face was so
disturbing it was so humiliating
I felt so humiliated for him because she
was screaming this is our home what the
[ __ ] are you doing
you're not making it's not a bloody home
the university is not a home right it's
not a safe space it's not a secure space
none of that and and if that when I get
a university isn't a home
that's not what it is it's a place to be
confronted by I would say often horrible
ideas you want to learn about history
you think that's gonna be safe do you
know what human history is like it's an
endless bloodbath with we know with with
a certain amount of hopeful progress
underlying it it's it's a it's a it's a
horror show and great literature is like
that and and and biology is terrifying
and physics is terrifying and you want
to be safe it's stay home stay home with
your mom stay home with your dad don't
come to university if you want to be
safe because we go outside no one of you
if you're going if the university is
going to make you safe than it ceased to
be a university so one of the things I
try to do in my class I have this class
called maps of meaning which
concentrates on atrocity basically on
Soviet atrocity and and Nazi atrocity
and what I try to do in the class is to
teach my students that had they been to
Nazi Germany in the 1930s they would
have been Nazis and had they be not
offered the opportunity to be in
Auschwitz
aash wits camp guard then maybe they
would have left out it and maybe they
would have been in the sadistic in the
more sadistic proportion of the
Auschwitz camp guard population you
think that makes you feel safe it
doesn't make you feel safe to know that
Nazis were humans and you happen to be
one of them so I think that educators
that tell students that they're offering
them a safe space are doing them a
profound disservice and you don't I'm a
clinical psychologist and here's one of
the things you do to make people less
afraid you don't make the world safer
what you do is you people tell you what
they're afraid of and then you break it
into little bits so that they can go
confront them you know so maybe they're
afraid of going to a party and you break
that down you say well do you know how
to introduce yourself and say well I
don't I don't really know how to shake
someone's hand and so then you practice
having them shake their hand and
introduce themselves because maybe they
weren't taught by that by their
half-witted parents when they were when
they were young because they were
ignored and so then you say well maybe
you can go to a party for half an hour
and all you have to do is introduce
yourself to two people and we'll call
that success and you build up their
confidence and their confidence one step
at a time and what happens the the
clinical literature
indicates quite clearly is you don't
make people less anxious by doing that
you make them braver it's not the same
thing
you don't make the world and its horrors
smaller you make the person and their
their capacity to deal with horror
larger you encourage them you strengthen
them that's what you do at a university
you armed people with arguments you you
hone their intellect you you help them
learn to write so they can marshal their
arguments you have you'll help them
learn how to engage in intellectual
combat because that's better than
engaging in real combat you make them
you make them hard and strong you don't
mollycoddle them and make them safe
unless you're their enemy unless you're
trying to devour their spirit and that's
what we have in the universities we have
we have the reign of the eda people
mother whose answered everything is oh
just come a little closer dear and I'll
protect you from the world it's just
like Hansel and Gretel's the you know
the witch in the Hansel and Gretel story
well my house is made of gingerbread
just come in here and everything will be
fine while she feeds a candy to fatten
you up so she can eat you that's the
archetype of a modern University
you